you've to tap the floor no you have to
find out what his nose
otherwise I'm doing the whole work for
him yeah except I'm here to challenge
him here if I tell him what everything
is then I'm not help him understand so
I'm really make him psychologically
blind he knows it's there he's being
stubborn okay found it he didn't know it
was there if he was there he wouldn't
eat it okay I'm not gonna put my hands
in there and get him out of there
physically I'm going to psychologically
get him out of there Shh okay I
corrected that yeah
I'm now going to let him tell me I'm
manipulating you come on I'm growling
you should give me the food no no I'm
not her whole different scent right so
now he's out this is what he wanted in
essence he's drawn me back to his
carrier where he is barking incessantly
and then I've lured him out you just
have to give it up get one up that he's
a human first
okay and I'm gonna say give it up for
Ellen you said put him in a different
order
he's animal dog breed human that's it
you can see him you know I mean every
single time he goes into that state
yeah the physical psychological touch
comes in through his brain to stop him
out of it right now I'm blocking him
from going back in there so I'm
suggesting a different choice a lot of
animals will go into their den or where
they feel most comfortable of right this
is just obsession you know he is he's a
little Howard Hughes but too you know a
mess is him being sort of an anxious
sort okay
reclaiming reclaiming the the box if
you're wanting to go back and then you
get it's gotta claim the box so he's
doing his his normal behavior he's
dodging me but he's not switching my
energy okay if you were to try to put
him on his back right now oh-ho and
brakeless Shh yeah that's good that's
right they don't share that energy King
I hate this life oh no oh you all right
he's not fighting here great but look at
the energy that is touching the body
that's very Terry we seen this many
times that's right okay okay that's
that's that he makes that he's not a
tame animal now I know it's not fixed he
can launch right back into that again
well yeah he lives with you but look at
the energy you're so calm I I'm a
nervous wreck because I know what he's
capable of and I I'm not thinking about
how many times he bit you I'm thinking
about how can I make him come that's
living in the now now you live in the
past you get what the past gives you
okay bad experiences
all right unless at least for today a
list for today force yourself if you can
just to live in the now okay
then you give affection when he's in
that state he's hot and bothered and
he's also what come surrendering hmm the
reason why he calmed down is because I
didn't feel sorry for him I treat him as
he was a normal dog see how you got up
yeah so I honor his dog way of being his
identity I let him be a dog around me so
can he trust me of course can he respect
me of course